san francisco
which has problems
san francisco not the most orderly city
in the world
san francisco
is
hoping to host its annual sex festival
it's a sex festival specifically for gay
men
it's called the up your alley leather
fetish festival
i actually hadn't even read the name i
read that there was this festival i
hadn't read the name that is
totally gross it makes the story even
grosser than initially i thought it was
so they have this leather
gay festival in san francisco not
exactly a man bites dog story but
but the
festival's taking place
while there is a virus that is spreading
at gay orgies so you would think they
would shut it down right no
san francisco refuses to shut down this
event
the the festival has been running since
1985
and they are not going to shut it down
even while a virus is spreading at the
gay orgies
it's not about what's safe it's not
about what's healthy it's about what do
we want to do
we we as a society well san francisco as
a society does not value church
does not value
small businesses does not value your
family having funerals for dead loved
ones does not value thanksgiving
celebrations does not value
high school graduations does not value
prom does not value any of the things
that got shut down for covid
but san francisco sure as hell values
gay leather orgies
and so
they're going to shut down all the first
ones they're not going to shut down that
last one and this it gets right back to
al gore's point this should not be
political
this should not why are we making this
issue of all your rights and your money
and your traditions in your country why
are we making this political
what this is about is what do we want to
do
what do we want to live with during
covid i
not only would have lived with
the risk of covet i not only would have
gone back to work and traveled and seen
my friends and gone to holidays and not
wearing the stupid mask and avoided all
the ridiculous measures that the lips
pushed on us but i actually did i did i
went back to work
they forced us all to work from home i
lasted 24 to 4 to 36 hours and then i
just went back to the studio and it was
pretty much just me and jeremy at the
studio for six months at a time because
i said i'm not doing this i'm not gonna
work from home i'm not gonna quarantine
i'm gonna go to all my holidays i'm
gonna go to easter
easter sunday dinner and i'm gonna
travel and i'm gonna i'm just gonna live
my life okay
i made that choice the political society
said no we're not gonna do that
okay but i i don't value gay orgies in
that way okay i don't value bath houses
and leather festivals and all that i
don't value that and i i don't think
there's any reason to tolerate that
stuff period but certainly not when
there's the spread of a virus
specifically at these places you have
the political right
to say that
no matter what they tell you on whatever
news show even if it's on a technically
or ostensibly right-wing news show
you have the right to say that you have
the right to moral views you have the
right to political views you have the
right to social preferences you have the
right to an opinion on matters of public
health and the economy
and the national order you have a right
to those things and you can say no al
gore i'm not going to let you make me
use those ugly fluorescent light bulbs
no san francisco i'm not going to let
you shut down my church and no i'm not
going to even let you keep the bath
houses and the leather parties open okay
we have
not just individual rights but there is
a higher sort of political right
those are political rights an individual
right is not not really political in the
sense that political is public it
involves other people and the founding
fathers talked about this and edmund
burke has talked about this and all the
great conservatives have talked about
how those that higher expression of our
liberty and our freedom is political
when we as a community say this is how
we want to live this is how we want to
flourish
speaking of the rainbow
a female soccer player has just been
sidelined for refusing to wear the
rainbow
her name is
jaylene daniels i'm not the
most up-to-date on female soccer
news uh she's the north carolina courage
defender and she was sidelined uh for
the team's friday soccer game because
she refused to wear an lgbt rainbow on
her jersey
she didn't agree with the rainbow she's
not down with the rainbow
and so she she didn't want to wear the
rainbow flag if you are a say christian
or or i would suspect a jew or a muslim
or if you have any kind of traditional
view of sexual ethics
you you can't wear the rainbow
so she says okay i'm not going to wear
the rainbow they said that's fine you
don't get to play you're going to be
discriminated against for your views on
these matters the team said jaylene will
not be rostered tonight as she's made
the decision not to wear our pride
jersey
while we're disappointed with her choice
we respect her right to set to make the
decision for herself we're excited to
celebrate the
plus
lgbtqia
with our fans players and staff tonight
and look forward to hosting our first
ever pride festival before knockoff
or before kickoff rather not knock off
would
you do you think it would be right to
force a jew or a muslim to wear a
christmas sweater
to work
let's say it's christmas time
and there's going to be a christmas
party at work whether we're talking
about they work at a soccer team or they
work at a an accounting firm do you
think it would be right to tell the jew
or the muslim hey you've got to wear the
christmas sweater in fact not just
you've got to wear you've got to wear a
nativity scene sweater
does that sit right to you for
most people
in our liberal culture they would say no
that doesn't sit right i don't know i
don't think you should do that would be
wrong
it is
much more egregious
to force someone to wear the rainbow
because while the christmas season is
deeply deeply embedded in our culture
and still we you wouldn't say like hey
hey ben hey shapiro put the christmas
sweater on no one would say that
but
the pride flag the pride movement is a
relatively new movement extremely
radical in our culture it's opposed by
huge swaths of our culture
now you're saying well if you won't wear
my version my sexual preferences my
contradiction of traditional sexual
ethics on your sleeve literally on your
sleeve then you don't get to come to
work
then you
practically speaking don't have a job at
least while i'm forcing everyone to wear
this
it's obviously wrong you can tell that
it's wrong when you put it in those
terms but the culture doesn't see that
it's wrong it goes right back to that
seinfeld episode where everyone tries to
make kramer wear the little ribbon
remember during aids everyone wore a
ribbon you said you have to wear a
ribbon especially in new york put why
aren't you wearing the ribbons i don't
want to wear the ribbon i'm you know i
hope people recover from this disease
but i don't want to wear the ribbon
well you have to work you all have to do
it you have to show that you are on my
team
when it comes to this political matter
and if you don't they'll crush you
they'll absolutely crush you i'm so glad
you like that clip now
you gotta ring that bell we hit a
million subscribers right before the
birth of my second baby how great is
that what a great birthday gift for him
great father's day gift for me
you can tell i haven't slept in days
make sure you ring that bell subscribe
let's get up to 10 million let's get up
to 1 billion subscribers here on this
platform we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]